-Our next guest is
a very funny actress,
comedian, writer
and producer.
The second season of her
Emmy-nominated show,
"A Black Lady Sketch Show"
airs Fridays on HBO
and is available to stream
on HBO Max.
Let's take a look.
-No!
-[ Chuckles ]
It was all so simple.
All I had to do was send a
message to the CIA Slack channel
and now the whole agency think
you're an enemy of the state
And now that you've killed me,
you've proven it.
You're as dead as I am, Trinity.
[ Gasps ]
Oh. [ Gasps ]
This was supposed to be
painless. [ Groans ]
That hurts very bad.
They don't tell you that.
Oh, they don't tell you it
hurts. Oh, God.
Aah!
Don't just watch me when I die
Oh, this is embarrassing.
You have no sympathy?
[ Moans ]
Oh, I'm still alive
and it's burning.
Oh, no, no, now I'm dead.
-Please welcome back to th
show, our friend, Robin Thede.
How are you, Robin?
-So good. That's ridiculous.
Honestly, one of the most
ridiculous deaths
in the history of television
-And this is a character
that only made a very smal
appearance in Season 1.
Deana is her name. What made you
want to bring her back?
Because it's
a lot of fun to watch.
-It's -- oh, thank you.
You know the show --
even a character with, like,
two lines in one sketch
can pop up with a really big
role in another one.
So, we just like to keep
people guessing.
Yeah, Season 1, she was just
talking to Kelly Rowland
of Destiny's Child fame
and had, like, two lines.
And then we thought it would b
really fun to bring her back
as a villain.
Ashley Nicole Black who play
Trinity, the invisible spy
always has these weird villain
who are looking to take her out.
So that was really fun.
-It must be very nice.
I feel like there was gap
in the time that you were
doing this show,
which is the pandemic starte
and you were still talking t
people about new shows they ha
and then there was this real
like, dead period
where there were no new show
for anybody to talk about.
And I feel like this is part o
the light at
the end of the tunnel.
Excuse me.
Do you feel that way?
Is it nice to be talking about
work that you have finished?
-It's so nice.
I mean, shooting it
during the height
of a pandemic was challenging.
But, you know,
we all came together
because we were one of
the first shows back,
because we wanted to
get this done.
And we wanted to get back
together and have fun.
I mean, we just have
so much fun together.
It's so joyful.
And I definitely think peopl
need this right now.
Just to laugh at something silly
and me having the world's
longest death.
You know, it's fun.
-You are not only
a writer on the show and a
performer on the show,
but you're the show runner
And I'm wondering how that works
when you're in the room
with your writing staff.
I'm assuming
writers you selected
when you put this show together.
Are they deferential
to your ideas
or are they honest with you?
-No, they're very honest.
They don't care that I created
this show.
That I star in the show.
They don't care.
If they don't think
something is funny,
they will just be like "Yeah
no, that's not good."
One time Holly Walker,
who is an amazing writer,
was with me at the nightly show.
Is now writing on Sam B.
She said -- I said some joke i
the room and it just fell flat
Like, just eight women looking
at me like I was ridiculous.
And I go, "Oh, you guys don'
want to laugh?" And Holly goes
"Robin, sometimes your jokes
don't land."
[ Light laughter ]
Just, like, knife to the heart
But you know what?
They make me better.
They make me better every day.
And that's the greatest thing.
-I have also worked with Holly
in the past and I'm pretty sur
I've heard something very
similar about my own work.
-She's harsh, but you know what?
She's so funny.
-Well, you know,
it's interesting.
I do think
it's important to hire --
one, talented writers,
and two, it's important
to hire writers who are honest
and then it's important to b
the kind of show runner
who listens
because ultimately that's
the only way it has any value.
-Yes, yes.
-Can we talk about
this character, Selena?
Because --
-Oh, my god.
-This is a hair style,
I've not -- How would you
describe that hair style?
-That hair style is pure
desperation
and just really
giving up on life.
This poor woman, Selena,
played a MASH game
back in elementary school
with her friend Ladonna,
and Ladonna miscounted.
So I was supposed to have th
mansion, be married to Omarion
have these kids.
You know,
have this wonderful life,
but she miscounted so that
I got a tragically sad life,
which included a cul-de-sa
receding hairline.
So, yeah, I saw that --
actually, during the pandemi
I was creating some of the looks
for these characters.
I had more time, right?
And I was like --
I was watching old episode
of "Murder She Wrote,"
and I saw a character,
a man, with that hair,
and I said,
"I think I want that hair.
[ Laughs ]
-I think I had thought of
watching "Murder She Wrote
during the pandemic,
that would have been
a better use of my time.
-Listen,
Peacock has all the episodes
Not to plug Peacock, but, yo
know, that's in your network -
-Hey, look,
if we've got the goods,
you've got to give
us the credit.
-You're right, and Peacock has
all of "Murder She Wrote."
So I give it up.
It has "The Amber Ruffin Show"
and all of "Murder She Wrote."
What more do you need?
-Yeah, that's a perfect
combination.
They cover all of womanhood.
-Yes. Exactly.
-Hey, one of the things wa
always interesting to me
about the show, Season 1, th
opening credits were puppets
-Yes, yes, we --
-I will say, like,
I find a lot of comedy writers
think, "Oh, puppets are funny.
But you came by this honestly.
You had a background in puppets.
-Yeah.
Yeah, so I'm a master puppeteer.
I was trained by a teacher fro
the Jim Henson School
when I was 13 years old.
I used to tour the country wit
a Christian puppet group,
believe it or not.
And I did this for three years
And so when it came time to do
this on the show, I was like
"Okay, I know
what we're going to do."
And everybody loved that open.
It was really fun
for the first season,
but I knew I wanted to
shake things up in Season 2.
-Yes, and Season 2,
we actually get to see you guys,
which is very nice.
-You get to see our faces.
We're not puppets.
This is like an homage to
"A Different World."
It's interesting.
It wasn't totally my decisio
to change the puppet open.
Actually, Billy Porter --
-The wonderful Billy Porter.
-You know, famed actor/singer,
amazing Billy Porter,
actually accosted me
at the "Black Women in Hollywood
Luncheon and said,
"Hey! Sorry I couldn't do your
show last season,
I was at the Met Gala."
You know, because we had asked
him to be on the show,
and he was very supportive
and sweet. But we understood
And he said, you know,
"I just want to tell you
the show is so good.
But I have to talk to you abou
one thing. I do have a note.
And I said, "Okay."
And he said, "The claymation."
And I was like, "What is h
talking about?"
And he said, "The claymation
you know, in the open."
I said, "The puppets?"
He said, "Yeah, yeah, yeah
the puppets.
So, I need to see your fac
and then your name.
Your face and then your name
Not the puppet and then a name
I don't know who you are based
on the name and the puppet
And all that being said,
what is your name?"
He had this like 15 minute
conversation with me
and didn't know my name, but
knew who I was, knew my show
So Billy Porter,
this is for you.
We have now our real faces
and our names.
But I think we'll switch it up
every year. It'll be fun.
-I feel like when you were
becoming a master puppetee
they should have taught you th
importance of making
the puppet so specific
to the actor
that this would never happen
-Look, I thought we did.
We had this amazing puppet shop,
Viva La Puppet in L.A.
who does all these amazing
amazing shows.
They do "Waffles and Mochi
with Michelle Obama.
I mean,
they're the best of the best
And our puppets do look like us.
I think he just wants to
see our human faces.
-I think that what we're finding
out is Billy Porter
has puppet blindness.
-I think we are.
-It affects a lot of people.
-Oh, my God.
This is an exclusive
to your show.
This is -- I'm glad that we go
to the bottom of this.
-You weren't just a travelin
puppeteer as a teen,
insofar as work you were doing
You hosted a show that,
again,
sounds like a made up show
for a sketch.
"Quad Cities Kids to Kids.
-Quad City Kids to Kids.
And it was a Saturday morning,
like, news magazine.
I burned all the footage
and pictures.
So apologies
that we have none of that.
But I would host this thing at
6:00 a.m. on Saturday mornings
on the FOX affiliate station
And they would send me out int
my town in Davenport, Iowa
and I would do
local news stories.
And one time,
they sent me to the Zoo --
the local Zoo,
which was tiny,
but they did have
two elephants there
and I was talking to the
zookeeper about them.
And I said, "You know, these
elephants don't look so good."
And he was like,
"No, no no, they're fine."
And shortly after the segmen
aired, he got fired.
They launched a whole
investigation
and he was actually, like, not
feeding the elephants properly
And little 13-year-old me
was like,
"These elephants don't loo
healthy enough."
I was very disturbed by it
So that started my whole,
kind of,
run in this righteous
television.
-I can't believe, like, they
were also public elephants
It seems like somebody who wen
to the zoo should have noticed
before the "Kids for Kids"
showed up.
-I think that speaks to ho
poorly attended the Zoo was.
-Right. He's like, "they'r
fine. Nobody ever comes here."
-Can you imagine?
He really --
-Hey, congratulations
on Season 2.
-Oh, thank you.
-It's always so nice to see you.
-Thank you. It's really fun.
We have two new cast members
this season
I'm really excited about.
So I hope people tune in.
-The second season of
"Black Lady Sketch Show"
airs Fridays on HBO.
And is available to stream
on HBO Max.